[Music]
so i got this um direct message on the
instagrams and it says this
dr d my 13 year old daughter will be
going back to class in school mid-august
um last year she was online all year
she's dealing with social anxiety and
depression how can i help her other than
getting a counselor which she already
has
how can i as a mother support her i feel
helpless
she has no friends today in her session
she just cried for 15 minutes when i
asked her what happened she said all i
was doing was practicing how to get to
know someone so when i go back to school
i can hang out
but i couldn't do it i had a panic
attack any tips will help
i'm so grateful for this question i'm
getting this all over the place listen
there will be no easy way back for
millions and millions and millions of
kids going to school
getting out um
this idea this is going to be easy is
there going to be three steps or five
step process there won't be it'll be
hard
and now with looks like the delta
variants on there's other schools
talking about going back online just to
start the school it's we're just going
to keep figuring this out
so here's a couple of things that you
can do and i don't have any notes here
this is just what i'm doing in my house
okay
um so this is coming from my head my
heart not from some
like
four tips to you know lose weight and be
a better not that this is just what i'm
doing in my house
um step number one you've heard me say
this over and over i'm gonna keep going
back and keep going back to it skin on
skin contact with your kids every single
day
from you that means you start every day
with a hug that means you um when they
get home from school you hold their hand
you hold their face you look them in the
eyes you tell them that you love them
you're glad to see them
um you don't just in your rear view
mirror when you're driving them go hey
how was it fine
cool
and you just go back you you have to
stop you have to bridge that awkward gap
between you and your five-year-old you
and your 13 year old you and your 19
year old whatever
touch their body
if they're okay with it
look them in the eye and say i'm so glad
that you're my kid
i know it's so bananas going back to
school and i'm in your corner and i'm so
glad
number two
you guys have to go move your bodies
together that means you're gonna have to
go outside and kick a soccer ball around
you're gonna have to not just have a
family movie now you have to go family
walk night
we're to do this together um if you've
got special needs kids if you've got
kids that just want to sit at home
you're going to have to figure that out
that could be as easy as we're just
going to go sit on the porch together
and i i don't know we're going to roll a
ball back i don't know what to make this
weird in that last call i just talked
about
we played the strangest game of tag
wrestle one of my kids started acting
like a cat and then we ended up swinging
each other i mean it was just
bongo for a while but we all got
sunshine none of us were wearing shoes
we got to contact the ground and um
we all got to laugh and we all got to
move our bodies around i also know that
i'm highly privileged living on a couple
of acres out in the woods
and if you're living in an apartment
downtown somewhere it's not so easy i
get that you got to figure it out you
got to get outside and you got to move
your body
even if that's stopping on the way home
from picking your kids up from school or
when they get off the bus you all go to
a local park i don't care what it is you
got to figure out a couple days a week
at least getting out and moving your
body together the third thing is
as safely as possible and as often as
possible you gotta have other kids
around your kid
whether that's a church group whether
that's a hey we're just gonna invite
four people over this is one of those
bring them over to watch a movie and eat
garbage i don't care they've got to be
in proximity to other kids
um so if you need to have pizza night
and come on overnight do it right if you
need to go buy a
um
we bought this little there it's like 10
bucks on amazon and it's a it
stretches out and you attach it and it's
a ping pong table that we just put over
our dining room table in the middle of
our living room like where our dining
table is we just got people over like
the aesthetics of the living room i
don't care anymore the kids are in a
crisis and so we're going to play ping
pong on our kitchen table and we're
going to eat on our front porch that's
what we've been doing um does it look
great nope is it going to scratch my
table up yup it is are my kids gonna
have memories of us figuring it out
along the way yes are we going to do i
get to smash a ping pong ball at my kids
and it makes me feel a little bit better
yes right um but we're gonna figure
those things out
and it could be puzzles on the middle of
the kitchen of the dining room table it
could be hey we're going to play games
every night we're going to
these cards that i'm sending out to you
guys um that are going to be available
to buy here in a month or two um
whatever it is we're going to have
direct connection with our kids they're
we're gonna have kids at our house if we
at all possible or i'm gonna have my kid
they're gonna be able to go to people's
houses we can do that safely
if you can't do it safely then we're
gonna go to parks we're gonna meet
places we're gonna do whatever and this
is what it's gonna cut into guys it's
gonna cut into our tv watching time
it's going to cut into an hour or two of
our sleep
my i'm tracking my sleep really closely
i've got this with this whoop strap
thing here my sleep is it's getting nod
off right i'm having to make other
adjustments i'm having to work out a
little bit differently i'm having to
change my diet i'm having to be highly
intentional because i'm getting less
sleep because i've got to put more of my
focus on
connecting with my kids in the mornings
and in the evenings
and
they're fraying at the edges not just my
kids all of our kids
um and then the fourth thing is
like i love this like we got a counselor
here what she said is so true
we're practicing re-entry
it's this could be one of the great
moments in history where we teach our
kids that relationships are something
you practice connection is something you
practice
so if you have a kid who's stressed out
practice hey what's it gonna look like
when you go back
practice being silly practice saying i
don't like your dress
and
what is it what's a good response
start practicing relationships with your
kids and by the way those of you going
back to work
same thing
those of you who are been working from
home and you're dying on the vine here
and you're gonna have to start going
back two days a week or three days a
week and then they're going to come home
you too because you got to practice
relationships too so it's going to help
you at your work environment as well
your work environment as well but what
your kids need right now is you to lean
in and you to figure out ways with even
if it's like hey you know what we're
gonna we're gonna start we're gonna play
fall soccer this year we're not even a
soccer family we're doing it now
we
we're playing
softball or baseball or
whatever the thing is we're having
saturday hike day let your yard grow a
little bit taller right i don't whatever
your thing is it's time to start getting
super creative
connection outside and making sure you
are touching and interacting with your
kids on a daily regular basis and all
that said
it's still going to be hard
some kids are going to really struggle
some kids are going to just zoom right
back into this no pun intended they're
going to get right back into it and
they're not going to miss a beat it's
going to be hard for everybody be really
gracious with yourself with your kids
stay connected to their teachers make
sure you've got a bunch of other adult
eyes looking on them if you can
do the best you can but lean into
connection thank you so much for that
instagram man that's good